hey guys Jeff here from wacky gamer I
decided to go through my cosplay footage
from Comic Con and just kind of do a
running commentary no preparation just
talk and see what comes out hope you
guys enjoy a loser in an owl Wolverine
so wants to get in that dude's skirt
yeah I'm watching you freak
uh-huh what bet did he lose to get the
spandex outfit no honey don't cover up
Oh put your tongue in sicko
he starts Asian dude female Jedi's
waffle pots to high me dude what's the
asian chick doing put some food in your
mouth women all but not that much room
cats don't really let herself go do the
follow chicks kind of hot
oh yeah it's another dude wonder which
of these guys is going to get killed
first that one without the facemask
they're hanging by the coke stand cuz
they know it mixes well with Rome sorry
about the camera guys and Jeff was
jumping up and down fat ass
you